حدثنا عن تبعات ما اوردناه للتو القناصون
موجودون على اسطح المنازل والاليات موجوده
ايضا في اماكن مختلفه
[موسيقى]
تفضل نع نعم العمليه العسكريه لا تزال
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه حيث لا يزال
الاحتلال ينتشر في كافه ارجاء مدينه طول
كرم لم يقتصر فقط على المخيم
وانما الاحتلال والياته العسكريه ينتشر في
كافه انحاء المدينه من غرب المدينه وصولا
الى شرقها حيث لا يزال الاحتلال يدفع بال
التعزيزات العسكريه بين الفينه والاخرى
هنا الى مخيم طول كرم في هذه العمليه
العسكريه المتواصله قوات الاحتلال نشرت
القناصه الاسرائيليه على اسطح المنازل
فيما لا يزال يتواجد جيش الاحتلال في هذه
الصوره عند المدخل الرئيسي يعرقل حركه
مركبات الاسعاف بالتزامن مع ذلك القناصه
الاسرائيليه تنتشر على اسطح المنازل اطلاق
نار صوب اي جسم متحرك في المنطقه يحاول
الاحتلال منذ ساعات الليل استهداف اكبر
عدد من الفلسطينيين في داخل المخيم حيث ان
الاحتلال حتى هذه اللحظه يسعى او يقتحم
المنازل واحدا تلو الاخر ينفذ اعمال ايه
مداهمه واسعه واعتقالات في صفوف الشبان تم
نقلهم وفتح مركز تحقيق وتوجيه ميداني في
منطقه شارع السكه لنقل الاعتقالات من داخل
المخيم بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه العسكريه
لا يزال الاحتلال بين الفينه والاخرى
يحاصر المخيم
وا يعرقل حركه الطواقم الطبيه وطواقم
الهلال الاحمر منذ ساعات الصباح تسعه
شهداء استشهدوا في
انفجار مسيرتين واحده في مخيم بلاطه في
مدينه نابلس والاخرى
انفجار مسيره ايضا بسياره داخل مخيم طول
كرم ادت ستشهاد اربعه فلسطينيين وفقا ل
طواقم الهلال الاحمر ومستشفى ثابت ثابت
الحكومي حيث تم نقل هذه الاصابات الى او
هذا هؤلاء الشهداء
الى المستشفى بعد عرقله واسعه من قبل
احتلال وتنكيل ب مركبات الاسعاف وبشه ايضا
الذين خرجوا في ساعات الصباح او عفوا
الذين خرجوا من داخل المخيم حيث يحاول
الاحتلال او مركبات الاسعاف اخراج هذه
الاصابات من داخل المخيم الا ان الاحتلال
لا يزال يعرقل حركه المركبات ايضا في
نابلس ايه الشهداء الخمسه وفقا لبيان
الجيش حيث ايه انه ايه صادر الجثامين وا
صادر المركبه ولا يزال حتى هذه اللحظه
يعني ايه شخصياتهم بشكل رسمي لربما بعضها
غير واضحه وهناك تناقل لعدد من الاسماء
هنا في مدينه طول كرم العمليه العسكريه
متواصله الحواجز تكاد تكون على كافه
الطرقات والمداخل المؤديه الى مدينه ال
طول كرم وبها وبها هؤلاء الشهداء الاربعه
يرتفع عدد الشهداء منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الى
364 شهيدا ومنذ بدايه هذا العام الى 45
شهيدا خلال اقتحامات الاحتلال المتواصله
لمدن الضفه الغربيه والتي ازدادت وتيرتها
حقيقه منذ السابع من اكتوبر حيث بتنا
يوميا نشهد اقتحامات واسعه ومداهمات
لقوات الاحتلال في انحاء متفرقه من
نعم
شفهيه الي هنا العمليه العسكريه لا تزال
مستمره والجيش على ما يبدو انه يؤكد
استمرار والمضي في هذه العمليه العسكريه
لربما لساعات